un accident impliquant un véhicule de la
STL qui sera rentré en contact avec une
garderie
tous ses vêtements il était totalement
nu on n'a pas compris pourquoi il a fait
ça on a plongé sur lui on a essayé de
maîtriser
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que
vous avez fait pour aider justement
on peut pas passer nous les chansons les
hommes
sont partout mais comme ça dans une coin
qu'il reste le garderies c'est
incroyable événement ce matin est une
tragédie d'une infinie tristesse c'est
effectivement une situation sans nom
l'image est presque irréelle elle n'a
pas de sens un immense autobus de la
Ville de Laval qui défonce une petite
garderie du quartier Sainte-Rose à Laval
tous les parents ont le cœur gros
aujourd'hui quand on va reconduire notre
enfant à la garderie le matin on
s'attend à le retrouver vivant en santé
le soir il est 8h30 ce matin la plupart
des enfants sont à l'intérieur de cette
garderie les parents seront rappelés
d'urgence et le pire est arrivé pour
deux familles qui apprendront que leur
petit est mort deux enfants tués 6
autres blessés par ce chauffeur de la
STL Pierre ni Saint Amant que des
parents et voisins ont d'ailleurs
immobilisé ce matin avant que la police
ne l'arrête on ne sait pas grand chose
du pourquoi de ce crime ignoble mais
avec ces images on comprend que ce matin
on a su très vite que le chauffeur avait
décidé
délibérément de foncer dans la garderie
vous voyez il y a ce carrefour il
fallait qu'il veuille entrer au bout
stationnement Jacques Audrey Charbonneau
vous êtes toujours à Laval c'était en un
mot la panique ce matin pour les parents
mal de nombreuses familles du quartier
Sainte-Rose ce matin et tournée au
cauchemar au chaos très rapidement il y
a même des parents ce matin qui nous
disaient Patrice qui était présent sur
place à 8h30 au moment du drame et qui
se considérait chanceux parce qu'ils
avaient pu serrer dans leur bras leur
petit alors que d'autres parents qui
n'ont pas pu le faire et qui étaient par
la suite dans des heures d'attentes
d'angoisse d'inquiétude d'incertitude
quant à l'état de santé de leur enfant
on sait qu'on s'est accroché aussi
beaucoup au fait qu'on pourrait sauver
tous les enfants on sait maintenant
qu'il y en a deux qui sont décédés 6
blessés bref ça a été une journée tendue
et difficile pour tout le monde ici
l'image est choquante percutante vers
8h30 un autobus de la société des
transports de Laval fonce dans la
garderie Sainte-Rose le bâtiment est
détruit
si la panique qui s'empare des parents
comme Nathalie Vaillancourt en fait mon
mari est venu porter notre Thomas la
garderie ce matin
un très grand impact un chauffeur
d'autobus que volontairement foncé dans
la garderie il y a rentré dans le local
des enfants plus âgés de la garderie des
40 ans son mari est intervenu auprès du
chauffeur agitée
qui est allé aider des parents à sortir
un petit garçon des décombres
le chauffeur quoi
il a ouvert la porte il a retiré tous
ses vêtements il était totalement nul on
n'a pas compris pourquoi il a fait ça on
a plongé sur lui on a essayé de
maîtriser c'est c'est ça réellement le
premier on l'a sorti et la deuxième
fille mais je sais pas par la suite
est-ce qu'ils ont trouvé d'autres
enfants non c'est un cauchemar je
n'arrive pas c'est horrible c'est
horrible un autre voisin vient en ren
pour maîtriser le chauffeur hystérique
trois dessus plus un qui est dalle
monsieur la casquette blanche quand je
suis rentré dans garderie il était nu à
terre recroquevillé avec le père qui
fait ce
qui se battait parce que lui il voulait
se sauver enfin qu'il fallait retenir la
police de Laval a évacué la garderie
l'école du parc a quelques centaines de
mètres devient une cellule de crise où
les parents terriblement inquiets afflux
espérant retrouver leurs enfants sains
et sauf Julia fait partie des chanceux
des parents pleurent inquiets parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de nouvelles de leur
enfant imaginez-vous on peut pas passer
non les chansons les hommes mais ils
laissent pas passer les parents tout le
monde doit attendre des indications des
policiers des policiers et des
politiciens aussi sous le choc événement
ce matin est une est une est une
tragédie d'une infinie tristesse parce
que le drame touche tout le monde les
ministres bonnardaient et Susanne droit
sont venus offrir de l'aide aux familles
il y aura des places déjà on a une très
très bonne collaboration des services de
garde à Laval tous les enfants pourront
retrouver une place dès demain je
souhaite que la VaR soit présent à
chaque étape pour pour les familles donc
nous serons au rendez-vous pour offrir
le support nécessaire quant au chauffeur
il a été arrêté un homme de 51 ans
employé de la STL a été arrêté pour
conduire dangereuse et homicides
l'enquête est en cours et le mobile
reste toujours inconnu ici la grande
question qui demeure sans réponse devant
un drame aussi inexplicable ici Jacques
Audric Charbonneau Radio-Canada Laval
pourquoi ce reton un jour pourquoi avec
exactitude on rejoint parce qu'elle
Robida qui est à Laval et Jacques
buissonnet au CHU Sainte-Justine il faut
pas oublier les 6 enfants blessés on va
faire avec vous le point Jacques mais
d'abord Pascal il a comparu de son lit
d'hôpital et il a été accusé de double
missiles entre autres
tout à fait Patrice le chauffeur qui a
utilisé un autobus de la Société de
transport de Laval a été arrêté ce matin
maîtrisé par deux parents à la garderie
éducative Sainte-Rose et par la suite on
l'a transporté à l'hôpital du sacré-cœur
où il a été gardé sous garde policière
et menotté à son lit une bonne partie de
la journée de sorte que ce n'est qu'un
vers 15h10 environ que les enquêteurs de
la police de Laval ont pu lui adresser
les premiers mots et vers 16h30 il a
comparer au palais de justice de Laval
par vidéo conférence et il fait face à
une kyrielle de chef d'accusation
extrêmement grave on voulait montrer
l'écran donc on parle de deux
accusations de meurtres prémédité pour
la mort de deux enfants qui étaient à
l'intérieur de la garderie ce matin
également des chefs d'accusation pour
tentative de meurtre et également voie
de fait grave il devrait revenir le 17
février prochain toujours au palais de
justice de Laval parce que on va
procéder évidemment à compléter le
dossier du côté des enquêteurs mais
aussi on veut l'évaluer du côté de la
prison de Bordeaux pour quant à savoir
s'il est apt a subir la suite des
procédures judiciaires voici le
directeur poursuite criminel et pénal
oui dans le fond le jeu se questionner
quant à latitude de la cuisine de
comparer ça a été confirmé monsieur
était art à comparer ce que questionner
le jeu c'est que le personnel
hospitalier voulait que Monsieur
Saint-Amand ait une évaluation
psychiatrique par contre c'était au
niveau de la dangerosité de Monsieur ils
n'ont pas de son attitude dans le fond
il y aura pas d'évaluation le niveau
concernant monsieur monsieur va être
transféré en détention parce que
monsieur est accusé au criminel il fait
face à des accusations donc dans les
circonstances il tombe sous la
responsabilité des services carcéraux
bon vous êtes allés dans son quartier à
Vimont qu'est-ce qu'on sait de ce
chauffeur d'autobus de Laval
ecoutez ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il est
âgé de 51 ans il n'a aucun antécédent
judiciaire et lorsqu'on a parlé avec son
employeur à la STL il n'a aucun dossier
de disciplinaire non plus il est
chauffeur d'autobus à Laval depuis une
douzaine d'années ses collègues de
travail ordonne l'ont décrit tout au
long de la journée comme un homme
extrêmement discret qui ne fait pas de
vagues et c'était la même chose du côté
de ses voisins où l'accusé a acheté une
maison en 2014 dans le quartier Vimont
il était très peu visible pour les gens
qui habitaient dans ce secteur c'est
l'onde de choc c'est le moi que l'on
peut se dire ce soir Patrice alors voici
quelques réactions
c'est terrible c'est terrible
les enfants j'en ai quatre petits
enfants moi puis c'est
terriblement là
c'est vraiment
dépassé je peux pas imaginer que j'ai
cette voisine calme et fait cette action
commence à cacher ça
merci beaucoup Pascal au revoir
il y a 4 enfants blessés qui sont
toujours hospitalisés
j'ai perdu la communication mais je sais
pas si vous m'entendez alors
effectivement 4 enfants ont été
transportés ce matin dans l'avant-midi
alors c'est deux garçons et deux
fillettes âgées de 4 ans et 5 ans qui
sont en observation actuellement il y a
un des trois enfants qui est
actuellement hospitalisé aux soins
intensifs mais selon les autorités
médicales on ne crée pas pour la vie
pour autant alors on parle ici de
polytraumatisme pour ce qui est de ses
enfants en ce qui concerne la méthode de
santé donc ça signifie sans doute des
fractures multiples pour plus de
précisions voici ce médecin de
Sainte-Justine
leur santé évidemment atteint mais leur
vie n'est pas mise en jeu au moment où
on vous parle c'est un polytraumatisme
donc c'est l'investigation complète qui
est actuellement offerte donc leur état
comme j'ai ils sont arrivés avec un état
de conscience préservé ce qui est quand
même une très bonne nouvelle mais il
reste que comme je vous dis l'évolution
va nous donner plus d'informations dans
les prochains 24 heures leuretup
psychologique va évalué dans les
prochaines heures actuellement toute
l'énergie a été mis pour s'assurer que
la famille soit auprès d'eux et qu'on
puisse leur offrir le meilleur soutien
qu'il soit psychologique mais c'est sûr
qu'on a toutes notre concentration est
actuellement sur les soins cliniques
pour s'assurer que aucun effet
secondaire aucun impact de ce qu'ils
viennent de subir aura sur leur vie
subséquente
il y a deux autres enfants Jacques
hospitalisé à la Cité de la santé à
Laval un troisième enfant qui avait été
transporté à Laval est décédé
malheureusement
ouais on a constaté son décès à
l'hôpital cité de santé trois enfants
donc les deux enfants hospitalisés sont
sous observation actuellement et à
l'hôpital évidemment c'est sacré tout un
état de choc que cette tragédie
finalement alors on peut on peut penser
en fait dans leur état de penser pour ce
qui est de du médecin entre autres on a
tout tenté pour sauver la vie du
troisième enfant voici quelques
explications là-dessus
on a reçu trois trois patients il y en a
deux qui demeurent sous observation et
une victime qui malheureusement est
décédée malgré les manœuvres de
réanimation dès qu'on a eu les premières
informations l'ensemble de du personnel
médical et paramédical c'est mobilisé on
peut parler des chirurgiens des pédiates
qui sont venus à la salle d'urgence en
prévision d'arrivée des victimes
la radiologie tout ce qui peut aider au
traitement et à l'investigation des
victimes avaient été mobilisés
voilà merci merci beaucoup j'arrive si
vous avez enfin si il a des nouvelles si
la fin de nous revenir sur ces quatre
blessés de 4 à Montréal 2 à Laval et
malheureusement les deux décès dont on
parlait il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
réactions politiques après la pause
François Legault monsieur Trudeau
également et à peu près tout le monde a
commenté aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs
monsieur Legault se rendra sur place
demain avec les autres chefs de parties
un père de famille
je t'ébranlé et puis je trouve ça
sur mes pensées sont vraiment que les
enfants avec les parents pas avec les
employés de cette garderie
un père de famille
je t'ai branlé et puis je trouve ça
je veux transmettre bien sûr toute ma
peine mon soutien aux familles
incompréhension et
on est très bouleversé
incompréhension on est très bouleversé
je pense que tous dans toute la classe
politique partout à Québec Ottawa on a
tenté d'expliquer et on a tout
simplement été des parents aujourd'hui
plutôt que des politiciens Véronique
bonsoir effectivement Patrice vous savez
il y a une ou deux journées par année où
il y en a pas de politique si au
Parlement parce que ça tout simplement
pas sa place parce que la classe
politique ressent un espèce de malaise
de faire de la politique et c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a vécu aujourd'hui
dans les couloirs de l'Assemblée
nationale d'abord parce que beaucoup
d'élus sont eux-mêmes parents qui sont
mis à la place des parents qui
angoissent justement à Laval il y en a
d'autres qui sont grands-parents bref
tout le monde s'est senti concerné et
touché donc au début de la période de
questions il y a eu un moment de
recueillement puis après ça quand je
disais qu'il y avait un certain malaise
à chaque fois qu'un élu s'apprêtait à
poser une question sans tel besoin de
dire tout juste avant en passant je vais
être solidaire avec les parents puis
leur dire que je comprends en ce moment
ce qu'ils vivent puis que je laisser des
aides le plus possible alors vous voyez
l'ambiance qu'il y avait et ça a
commencé très tôt ce matin avec ce
commentaire de monsieur Legault
et on va offrir
aux parents toute l'aide qu'on est
capable de leur donner mais évidemment
là comme père de famille
j'étais brandis et puis je trouve ça
je peux comprendre
l'angoisse qui vivent actuellement donc
mes pensées sont vraiment que les
enfants que les parents pas avec les
employés de cette garderie
qu'on a entendu Paul Saint-Pierre
Plamondon jeune papaye tout le monde qui
partout dans l'opposition là on avait la
même réaction humaine et puis d'ailleurs
demain autant François Legault que les
chefs des parties d'opposition vont tous
se rendre ensemble à Laval il y en aura
pas de partisannerie vont être là pour
soutenir les parents ils seront en
présence de la police de Laval du maire
de Laval aussi pour tenter de répondre
le plus possible aux questions puis ici
à l'Assemblée nationale le drapeau va
être en berne les travaux parlementaires
vont quand même se poursuivre même si
personne a le cœur à ça voici maintenant
les chefs des parties d'opposition
nous voulons envoyer notre notre
solidarité nos prières également
accompagnent les victimes et les proches
des victimes en tant qu'enseigne
concerne municipal de Sainte-Rose ce
sont mes voisins j'habite à côté de
l'endroit où ça s'est passé donc je suis
extrêmement bouleversée je pense aux
enfants à leurs parents je pense aussi
au travailleurs et aux travailleurs de
la garderie au premier répondant on va
aider comme on peut mais incompréhension
on est très bouleversé
merci beaucoup à Véronique à Québec et
puis évidemment Ottawa aussi le drame
que résonné comme nous dit Christian
Noël
et les honorables députés de se lever on
entend toute l'horreur l'incompréhension
la tristesse
une douleur profonde ressentie jusque
dans l'enceinte du Parlement nous sommes
tous de tout cœur avec les familles
touchées par cette tragédie insensée
comme père de famille je peux imaginer
la souffrance des familles affectées et
nous offrons tous notre support et nos
prières pour les familles là nos enfants
sont ce que nous avons de plus précieux
et ce qui est survenu ce matin nous
classe le sang nous sommes tous sur le
choc une vague de sympathie qui secoue
les cœurs peu importe la couleur
politique c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
pourrait pas imaginer c'est une tragédie
vraiment
nous bouleverse tous
personne qui fait l'abri d'une tragédie
semblable mais ça fait vraiment mal et
nos pensées accompagnent les victimes et
des familles des victimes je n'ai pas
les mots pour exprimer comment c'était
horrible beaucoup de compassion beaucoup
d'empathie pour les gens de pas en
général mais singulièrement pour les
familles il n'y a rien de plus
précieux dans nos coeurs à tous que les
enfants en matinée l'information filtrée
au compte-goutte l'incertitude et le
désarroi gagné les députés du coin
un mot de reconnaissance pour les
premiers répondeurs et une main tendue
pour la communauté touchée nous serons
là pour offrir toi tout à l'appui qu'on
peut un moment de recueillement pour les
enfants perdus et pour les parents qui
n'auront pas de câlins ce soir ici
Christian Noël Radio-Canada
Ottawa
restez là après la pause entre autres
une entrevue avec la docteur Marie-Eve
cotton médecin psychiatre
[Musique]
on a pas compris pourquoi il a fait ça
on a plongé sur lui on a essayé de
maîtriser maîtriser
[Musique]
suspects
beaucoup de parents panés quand ce matin
vraiment une nouvelle tu veux pas te
lever avec ça ce matin
les parents de d'autres enfants qui
étaient blessés je sais pas qu'est-ce
que je veux faire parce que des malades
là sont partout mais comme ça dans une
coin qui le reste les garderies c'est
incroyable
[Musique]
Sébastien bonsoir vous nous en parler un
peu plus tôt ce qui était avec nous la
scène de crime va rester encercler
pendant un bon bout de temps exactement
un périmètre de sécurité autour de la
garderie ce qui fait en sorte que nos
collègues n'ont pas pu approcher
aujourd'hui mais quand même des images
nous permettent de comprendre un peu
mieux ce qui s'est passé surtout pour
ceux de Montréal ou d'ailleurs qui ne
sont pas familiers avec le secteur alors
on est à Laval dans le secteur
Sainte-Rose c'est au nord de la ville la
garderie éducative Sainte-Rose marquée
par le point rouge ici est au bout donc
de la terrasse du frein c'est une rue
qui s'arrête juste avant le chemin de
fer du Canadien Pacifique on va le voir
un peu mieux ici vous voyez il y a un
rond-point au bout de la rue un
stationnement au bout duquel se trouve
un édifice avec un toit rouge c'est la
garderie en question la garderie
éducative Sainte-Rose alors il y a bel
et bien un arrêt d'autobus ici de la STL
de la Société de transport de Laval la
ligne 151 mais a priori aucune raison
pour laquelle un autobus entrerait dans
le dans ce stationnement là surtout pas
à grande vitesse alors qu'on sait dans
cette fois-ci qu'il est allé percuter de
plein fouet la façade de cette garderie
donc vous ne comprenez bien il est
difficile de croire qu'il s'agit d'un
accident on a déjà vu des véhicules
percutés la façade d'un édifice souvent
sur un boulevard par exemple la grande
vitesse près d'une intersection un
accident par exemple mais là ce n'est
pas le cas est-ce que le conducteur a
une perte de contrôle un malaise un bris
mécanique on ne sait pas des parents
d'affaires là c'est ce que vous dites
pas là d'aucune façon normalement les
parents nous ont dit ne pas avoir vu de
traces de freinage les dommages sont
considérables mais est-ce que c'était un
geste délibéré c'est l'enquête qui nous
le dira Patrice comme le rappelle
d'ailleurs Marcel savoir ex directeur
adjoint de la Sûreté du Québec à qui
vous avez parlé un peu plus tôt
on dit tous Actuellement et on entend
les gens les différents journalistes les
médias les autorités politiques dire ça
ne se peut pas que ça soit un accident
et on connaît le conducteur pour les
policiers Patrice là il y a rien
d'évident ils vont devoir démontrer
d'abord que c'est le conducteur et ils
vont devoir le démontrer d'une façon qui
est juridiquement acceptable à la cour
c'est-à-dire on va aller chercher est-ce
que du vidéo qui le montre au volant on
va faire une preuve totale et complète
comme si on n'avait pas eu une
arrestation citoyenne d'un conducteur
qui sort de l'autobus on met ça de côté
complètement deuxième chose on dit le
véhicule ce n'est pas un accident encore
là on va recommencer l'enquête on va
démontrer que le véhicule il n'y a
aucune brille mécanique sur ce véhicule
on va montrer que le véhicule
était vraiment fonctionnel que les frais
fonctionnaient
même si on connaît la conclusion de
l'enquête de toute évidence monsieur
ce que Monsieur Savard explique qu'il
est important c'est qu'il faut quand
même qu'ils en face la démonstration
peut pas faire l'économie de cette
enquête qui sera longue et technique
c'est un événement rarissime Sébastien
et vous avez peut-être vu aujourd'hui en
tête des attaques au camion bélier par
exemple ce sont produites au cours des
dernières années que ce soit à Berlin à
Nice ou même à Toronto en 2018 mais la
plupart du temps dans ces cas-là les
victimes étaient des piétons là que ça
se produit dans une garderie alors que
les enfants étaient à l'intérieur ça
choque et pas qu'au Québec au Canada
vous voyez la plupart des grands médias
à travers le monde que ce soit de
gardien de New York Times CNN BBC évoque
le drame qui s'est produit aujourd'hui à
Laval alors ça témoigne du choc la
tragédie donc fait le tour du monde
merci beaucoup Sébastien je vous en prie
avec nous docteur Marie-Eve coton que
vous connaissez médecin psychiatre
professeur bonsoir docteur coton bonsoir
Patrice je parlais à un de vos collègues
tout à l'heure docteur Chamberland et
qui faisait une différence importante
parce que pour nous qui regardons ça ce
matin on dit il est fou là ça prend un
fou pour s'attaquer à des jeunes enfants
victimes là dans une garderie impuissant
des petits bouts de chou mais entre le
langage populaire dit quelqu'un est fou
et la folie
codifiée il y a un pas il y a une marge
là où vous en êtes dans votre réflexion
on est quelques heures après le drame ce
matin
c'est des questions importantes c'est à
dire qu'il y a pas de doute je pense
pour n'importe qui que c'était cet
individu-là devait être souffrant devait
être en détresse maintenant être en
détresse puis être malade c'est deux
choses différentes et c'est important de
le mentionner moi mon message est
beaucoup de dire attention
quotidiennostique précipité de problèmes
de maladies mentales dans les heures
suivant une tuerie comme celle-là je
trouve que c'est beaucoup ce qui s'est
passé suite à la tuerie du Vieux Québec
où les ministres les journalistes
parlaient de troubles de santé mentale
avant même que psychiatre est rencontré
l'individu donc c'est important parce
que les camps on regarde les études sur
les soirs de masse il y en a 22% qui ont
une maladie mentale importante le haut
que le problème de consommation un
trouble de personnalité donc c'est
possible que cet individu là a été sous
l'emprise une psychose d'hallucinations
mais ce n'est pas l'unique possibilité
ce n'est même pas la possibilité la plus
importante sur le plan statistique donc
c'est important de de garder l'esprit
ouvert de pas spéculer de façon stérile
avec seulement des brides d'information
parce que ce qui arrive c'est que dans
des tragédies comme ça très morbide on
est très pro à
parler de maladies mentales et ça
stigmatise énormément les gens qui ont
des maladies mentales vous savez
aujourd'hui les gens dans la population
ils ont deux points 5 plus de chances
qu'en 1950 de dire que les gens qui
sautent de schizophrénie sont violents
et je pense que cette
association là médiatique entre une
espèce d'automatisme de ce genre associé
cette ce genre de tuerie avec la maladie
mentale elle est très très néfaste pour
les gens qui ont des problèmes de santé
mentale je comprends très bien et au
terme de la loi c'est loin d'être sur
même si lui plaidait la non
responsabilité pour cause d'aliénation
mentale c'est loin d'être sûr qu'il
obtiendrait c'est difficile à faire la
preuve mais je reviens à la réaction
normale que nous avons devant ces drames
là est-ce qu'une personne saine d'esprit
peut commettre ce genre d'action là
une personne
une personne qui est parfaitement
équilibrée qui a une vie épanouissante
et tout ça non mais on n'a pas besoin
d'être malade pour être malheureux ça
c'est vraiment le message que j'ai à
transmettre c'est à dire que le profil
des gens qui font des surrénes bases
c'est des très majoritairement des
hommes très majoritairement des
individus qui sont isolés socialement
ils sont pas bien intégrés dans la
société dans un emploi dans une famille
etc sont plutôt les gens solitaires ils
ont souvent des problèmes de
consommation ils ont souvent subi du de
l'exclusion et du bowling c'est-à-dire
de du harcèlement soulever ou de
l'intimidation dans leur vie donc ils
peuvent avoir une certaine rencard donc
ils ont souvent un vécu et motif
lourd difficile mais c'est pas parce
qu'on souffre parce qu'on est intimidé
qu'on a une maladie mentale et les gens
qui versent en des crimes haineux
souvent la haine et la violence va
s'alimenter de la détresse c'est à dire
que quand les gens sont pas heureux sont
pas satisfaits de leur vie qui ont et
qui ont subi eux-mêmes de la violence ou
qui ont été témoins ils vont plus
facilement verser dans des crimes mais
la haine comme telle c'est pas une
maladie mentale il faut faire la
distinction c'est intéressant la haine
n'est pas une maladie mentale ce qui ce
qui entraîne un niveau de haine comme
celui-là qui peut expliquer un geste
comme ça c'est c'est des c'est difficile
à concevoir vous allez reconnaître avec
moi si tu fais la concevoir pour un
parent entre guillemets normal mais vous
dites c'est pas dire qu'il était fou là
le mot folie je ne le contrôle pas parce
que c'est pas un terme médical donc si
les gens veulent dire c'est quelque
chose que je trouve fou c'est pas la si
nécessairement mon combat mais c'est pas
tous les gestes immoraux ne sont pas de
la maladie mentale la maladie mentale
c'est pas une espèce de bassin non
spécifique où on peut mettre tous les
les comportements humains qui sont
morbides ou qui je veux dire
tragique ou qui sont immoraux ou qui
sont violents c'est plus compliqué que
ça et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs je vous
laissais aller je pense vous devez y
aller c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
devant les tribunaux je le répète c'est
important ce n'est pas parce qu'on
plaide la liation mentale puis que la
déconnexion avec le réel qu'on l'obtient
là c'est tombé dans une case maladie
mentale c'est pas facile en cours en
fait c'est que les gens sont saines
d'esprit jusqu'à preuve du contrat sont
présumés Saint-Esprit pour être trouver
non responsables il faut prouver deux
choses soit que la personne savait pas
ce qu'elle faisait donc elle savait pas
que rentrer dans avec le bus vous pouvez
tuer quelqu'un ou que pensait pas que
c'était mal par exemple si la personne
est sous le coup d'hallucination qui lui
dit faut que tu poses ce geste là pour
sauver l'humanité parce qu'elle est sous
l'emprise d'un délire en disant ça va
être la fin du monde si tu le fais pas
là les gens le font mais on l'impression
de faire ça pour le bien si vous voulez
là si l'avocat peut montrer ça là ça va
conduire mais même si on a une maladie
mentale ça c'est important aussi on peut
avoir une maladie mentale mais qui était
pas suffisamment sévère pour que
justement soit on sache pas ce qu'on
faisait ou on sache pas que c'était mal
donc même la maladie mentale c'est pas
un passeport automatique vers la non
responsabilité criminelle très bien
docteur coton on va se reparler là parce
que en fait le message que vous envoyez
c'est à l'ont pas trouvé puis on
comprend le message pour mettre des
étiquettes de maladies mentales parce
que des gens qui sont vraiment malades
mentaux
qui sont en proie des maladies mentales
qui ne veulent pas être associés
justement à ces folies-là absolument et
les gens qui souffrent de maladies
mentales sont très peu violents en fait
ils sont beaucoup plus à risque d'être
victime de violence que d'être eux-mêmes
désagrégresseur donc faut pas rajouter à
leur adversité docteur merci à la
prochaine au revoir
et le chauffeur en question a été jugé
première étape qui suit cette discussion
elle a été jugée apte à comparaître il a
comparer on vous le disait plutôt par
vidéo conférence palais de justice de
Laval il fait face à neuf chefs
d'accusation dont deux pour tentatives
de meurtre prémédité pardonnez-moi après
la pause
Laval Stéphane Boyer et à la ministre de
la Famille Suzanne Roy
et c'était une scène quand même assez
difficile à voir les familles qui
couraient qui
tentaient d'avoir des nouvelles de leurs
enfants c'est inconcevable quand on
obtient ce matin le temps s'est arrêté
parce que c'est tellement concevable ça
peut pas être vrai ça peut pas il peut
pas être arrivé ça chez nous
[Musique]
frustration c'est des enfants là c'est
toujours pourquoi la question pourquoi
il y a pas de réponse shoot de bon des
mauvaises nouvelles c'est pas bon pour
personne mais quand ça touche les
enfants là c'est encore trois fois plus
terrible dix fois plus terrible
le choc a été puis vous le savez vous
suivez ça depuis ce matin comme nous le
choc a été encore pire pour les gens de
Laval j'ai parlé un peu plus tôt avec le
maire de Laval Stéphane Boyer qui était
évidemment secoué on va en écouter un
extrait suivi de la ministre de la
Famille Susanne roi qui promet qu'on ne
va pas oublier tout le personnel de la
du service de garde les gens qui ont
besoin d'aide les gens et les premiers
intervenants etc que personne dit elle
vous allez l'entendre va tomber dans une
craque on écoute
Monsieur le Maire bonsoir
bonsoir alors c'est un coup dur c'est un
coup dur vous l'avez dit ce matin
ça fait des années qu'on a des coups
durs c'est il y a eu la pandémie ceci et
cela vous l'avez dur à Laval celle-là
dépasse d'un cran encore
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour aider
d'abord votre communauté et vos premiers
réactions ce matin vous j'ai envie de
vous demander d'abord quand vous avez
appris ça autour de 8h45 là il y a 8h30
à l'hôtel de ville donc on a mis fin à
la Réunion pour aller tout de suite sur
les lieux rencontrer les familles voir
qu'est-ce qui se passait évidemment les
premières actions c'est
difficile de mettre des mots sur sur ce
qui se passe c'est la tristesse la
colère l'incompréhension
aujourd'hui plusieurs familles ont reçu
un appel qu'on espère jamais recevoir
dans une vie
et
c'était une scène quand même assez
difficile à voir
des familles qui couraient qui
tentaient d'avoir des nouvelles de leurs
enfants
et je pense que ce qui rajoute à
l'incompréhension ou de là évidemment du
deuil
c'est le geste en soi pourquoi est-ce
que quelqu'un
foncerait délibérément sur une garderie
où il y a plusieurs enfants
l'enquête nous dira un peu plus je
l'espère sur les motifs mais évidemment
aujourd'hui Laval c'est une communauté
en deuil
pour la pour les familles qui évidemment
ont perdu dans certains cas un enfant
pour d'autres que leurs enfants est
blessé mais c'est aussi bien plus que ça
c'est le personnel qui était sur place
la personne la garderie c'est le
voisinage et des voisins qui ont dû
intervenir sur la scène
et c'est tout le personnel d'urgence nos
policiers nos pompiers nos ambulanciers
sont quand même habitués à l'intérieur
dans des situations d'urgence mais cette
fois-ci c'était quelque chose d'autre
quand on voit un enfant qui vit sur le
sol
c'est des images qui nous marquent et
donc aujourd'hui c'est toute une
communauté et moi comment lavage je veux
que la communauté réponde présente pour
pouvoir supporter chaque citoyen saxoine
qui est impacté mais c'était important
ce que vous dites donc comment ça va se
déployer cette aide parce que vous le
dites bien est un accident de voiture
sur un accident de voiture c'est
terrible ça peut décimer une famille
mais là il y a un geste délibéré
contre des enfants impuissants qui
étaient en train de jouer à la garderie
alors comment va se déployer l'aide pour
les policiers les pompiers les
travailleurs on parlera la ministre plus
tard aussi pour les éducatrices et tout
ça comment on s'arrange là
oui donc essentiellement c'est de l'aide
psychologique qui est offert donc
rapidement après l'événement on a occupé
une école qui était à proximité où on a
rassemblé les parents on a rassemblé les
enfants où il y a eu du support
psychologique qui était offert et ce
sport là on va continuer à l'offrir au
cours des prochains jours parce que
évidemment dans les médias la personne
peut subir un choc peut être en
traumatisme mais des fois sous l'effet
d'adrénaline on peut se sentir bien mais
c'est le lendemain c'est la semaine
suivante où on va sentir les
répercussions pour moi c'est vraiment
important qu'on soit là pour nos gens
peu importe au moment où ils en auront
besoin donc il y a eu dans un premier
temps les services déployés sur le site
il y a des services aussi déployés
d'aide psychologique par exemple à la
STL à la société transport de Laval
parce qu'il y a aussi des de nos
chauffeurs d'autobus qui connaissaient
cet individu c'était un collègue qui ont
impacté par l'événement donc le service
d'aide psychologique a été offert sur
place mais le sera aussi sur les lieux
de travail et de sera aussi au fil des
prochaines journées tendre son temps que
un besoin sera ressenti nous serons là
pour
avec nos sujets de roi ministre de la
Famille du Québec dans le droit bonsoir
bonsoir On est tous un peu ministre de
la Famille au Québec on se sent tous les
parents se sentent le cœur gros
évidemment vous êtes allés sur place
d'avoir vos premiers commentaires c'est
l'épouvantable c'est un tragédie son nom
vous le disiez en tous les parents se
sentent concernés tous les parents tous
les grands-parents du Québec sentaient
des émotions quand on a entendu ça ce
matin tout le monde pensait ce que
pouvait ressentir les parents alors
l'inquiétude des parents et là on
apprend que deux décès alors évidemment
on offre nos sympathie aux familles mais
c'est incroyable parce que le matin on
va porter notre petit à la garderie là
le temps s'arrête normalement on dit bon
notre enfant est en sécurité pour la
journée et il y a une tragédie comme
celle-là un autobus bélier qui fonde sur
nos enfants alors c'est absolument
inconcevable bon là il y a le choc puis
on lui disait avec le maire de interval
ce qui était avec nous un peu plus tôt
il faut s'occuper des gens qui étaient
là sur le terrain ce matin des
éducatrices des pompiers des policiers
leur offrir de l'aide comment tu fais
les coordonnées alors dès le départ
c'est le sud de Laval qui a envoyé des
intervenants psychosociaux pour soutenir
les familles soutenir les employés bien
sûr il va aussi y avoir un suivi auprès
des ambulanciers des policiers les
premiers qui sont intervenus sur les
lieux il va aussi avoir du suivi par la
suite parce que oui aujourd'hui c'est un
immense mais dans les jours qui vont
suivre aussi on va voir la profondeur de
cette tragédie là alors il va continuer
à avoir du suivi pour les familles pour
les travailleurs de la garderie mais on
a aussi immédiatement déployer sur place
les gens du ministère pour s'assurer que
par exemple aujourd'hui ont contacté
tous les parents pour connaître leurs
besoins en termes de service de garde
pour pouvoir leur offrir des places
connaître le besoin des enfants au
Québec arrêtons-nous là-dessus une
seconde tous les parents qui ont des
enfants c'est le garderie là à
Sainte-Rose ont été appelés déjà on leur
a offert un plan B c'est pour demain
après-demain là oui tout à fait et il y
a suffisamment de place on a eu une
belle collaboration je pense qu'on a vu
une belle solidarité de la part des
garderies venir nous dire que il y avait
des offres pour des places s'il y avait
des besoins pour des employés tout ça
pour remettre les choses en place alors
oui chaque enfant chaque parent a été
contacté et puis pour vraiment répondre
aux besoins des enfants et dans les
médias donc il y a personne qui tourne
dans une crainte il faut surtout pas
déjà ça a été horrible pour ses parents
là aujourd'hui on parle bien sûr aux
parents dont les enfants sont décédés
ont été blessés mais tous les parents
aujourd'hui ont vécu un angoisse
ça fait peur j'espère que non mais cette
garderie là était pas dans une situation
où elle était propice à avoir un
accident c'est pas un tournant qui s'est
pris trop vite mais on accroché la
galerie donc c'est très sécuritaire elle
était quand même éloignée de la route
alors c'est malheureusement un geste qui
semble être volontaire on va le voir il
compare aussi dans quelques instants
mais difficile effectivement de se
prémunir contre tous les risques mais on
veut que nos enfants soient en sécurité
et on ne veut pas vivre dans cette
société où on devra avoir des clôtures
là où nos enfants devraient être en
sécurité exactement et on le disait
plutôt je faisais la remarques plutôt on
a avec Marie-eve Bédard des images et
plus rentables d'enfants dans un
tremblement de terre on se dit on vit
sur la terre il y a des risques des
terriens là tremblement de terre c'est
naturel
mais que quelqu'un s'attaque à une
garderie que l'autobus il y a quelque
chose d'absolument absurde et de
révoltant c'est inconcevable on a pris
ça ce matin le temps s'est arrêté là
parce que c'est tellement concevable
qu'on ça peut pas être vrai ça peut pas
il peut pas être arrivé ça chez nous
avec nos enfants
je suis un roi merci d'être venu nous
voir on va on va malheureusement suivre
ça une enquête qui sera longue
minutieuse il faut reconstituer tout ça
et je le rappelle donc le le suspect le
chauffeur est accusé actuellement au
palais de justice de Laval merci
beaucoup madame merci au revoir
[Musique]
il faut retour déjà viennent se
recueillir sur la place à la garderie on
y retourne avec Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau en direct
[Musique]
on retourne sur les lieux du drame vous
voyez ces images d'enfants qui viennent
porter des fleurs sur cette voiture de
police jacaudrai rebondoire alors
forcément une ambiance qui est lourde ce
soir
oui dans le quartier de Sainte-Rose à
Laval on sent c'est tendu j'ai entendu
beaucoup de commentaires des gens qui
sont en colère justement contre ce qui
s'est passé donc des voisins qui
viennent se recueillir il y a un
périmètre de sécurité qui est encore
érigé près de la garderie donc les gens
déposent des peluches des germes de
fleurs ici sur une toute police qui est
là pour faire le périmètre de sécurité
avec la garderie
il y a aussi des enfants qui sont
ébranlés parce que rappelez-vous je vous
l'indiqué un peu plus tôt la cellule de
crise a été établie dans l'école
primaire qui est à quelques mètres d'ici
donc les enfants de la garderie les
parents ont été dans l'école une bonne
partie de la journée il y a beaucoup
d'enfants de 6 ans 7 ans 8 ans là qui
ont été très ébranlés par tout ce qui
s'est passé j'en ai rencontré
quelques-uns des témoins des voisins
aussi qui tenaient à venir voir à offrir
leur condoléances aux familles des deux
enfants qui sont décédés mais aussi des
familles de toute la garderie le
personnel aussi on va écouter quelques
commentaires
je me dis que c'est terrible de vivre à
faire la même si tu veux pas vivre ça
c'est fou c'est c'est vraiment un
événement tragique en fait on imagine
pas qu'un drame Paris puisse arriver
juste à côté de la maison donc ça a été
intense on est allé déposer quelque
chose en hommage aux enfants soutiens
voir c'est soutenir les gens parce que
c'est dur là moi des choses comme ça ça
vient me toucher automatiquement surtout
des enfants et tout là surtout si c'est
volontaire là ça ça vient me chercher là
moi c'est un peu de la colère de la rage
devant quelqu'un qui veut faire du mal
volontaire des enfants
oui de la colère et de la rage on peut
tout à fait comprendre on rappelle le
bilan Jacques audrais deux enfants tués
6 blessés et les gens posaient des
questions là peut-être pas précisé assez
clairement au début de l'émission il
était seul dans cette autobus tout porte
à croire qu'il était seul dans l'autobus
le chauffage
voilà vous avez les bons mots Patrice
tout porte à croire qu'il était seul
parce que les policiers n'ont pas encore
confirmé cette information là par contre
on a parlé à des témoins les gens qui
sont intervenus et on a entendu
justement des témoins qui sont
intervenus pour maîtriser le chauffeur
il y en a un qui m'a dit j'ai tenté
d'entrer par l'arrière de l'autobus et
j'ai constaté qu'il était vide donc
selon nos informations on peut dire que
il était seul dans l'autobus mais c'est
encore à confirmer merci beaucoup
Jacques Audrey des journées longues
aussi pour les gens pour vous toute
l'équipe le sur place c'est difficile il
y a beaucoup d'émotions merci beaucoup
merci
[Musique]
c'est une histoire qui nous a fait tous
basculer dans un immense trou noir on ne
sait pas pourquoi on verra au cours des
prochains jours nos pensées ce soir